وارحب بضيفي من موسكو العقيد باسيلي
فاتيكاراف الضابط الاحتياط في البحريه
الروسيه سيد فاسيلي ربما استمعت لما تحدث
به
ضيفنا ضيفنا من اوديسا حول طبيعه الهجوم
بانه لا توجيه رسائل وانما هو ياتي في
سياق الرد الطبيعي الذي تقوم به
لما يجري من حرب من وجهه نظرها
كيف تقرا روسيا مثل هذا الاستهداف اليوم
لمقر اسطولها
كل ما قاله
المتحدث السابق ولكن على العكس نحن نفهم
جيدا انها انه مبنى تاريخي اثري للقوات
البحريه لذلك في الاوقات الحربيه لا احد
يتواجد في هذا المبنى المتواجد على جبل في
مركز المدينه عدا عن ذلك الهجمه الرمزيه
التي تسمى ضربه في القلب
هذه هذا المبنى هو يرمز او بنفس قوه
الكرملين في موسكو فهم ضربوا رمزا مهم
مهما جدا للبحريه الروسيه وهذه عمليه
رمزيه سوف يتحدثون عنها لفتره طويله وليس
هناك اي معنى استراتيجيا عسكريا في هذه
الهجمه لذلك الاداره الغربيه
شركاء بل هم ملاك
لاوكرانيا بالطبع سوف يقدموا لهم اسلحه
بعيده المدى لان الولايات المتحده مهتمه
باضعاف روسيا وتصعيد هذا النزاع ونحن سوف
نرى المزيد والمزيد من الاسلحه التي سوف
تقدم لاوكرانيا وبالطبع سوف يستخدموها بكل
الاماكن ضد المنشات المدنيه في دنيسكو وفي
وضد مختلف المنشات وهذه الماساه ليست
بالصدفه لقد هاجموا كيف يمكن ان تتصرف
موسكو ازاء استهداف
لهذا المبنى الذي تتحدث بانه ذو رمزيه
كبيره مثله مثل الكرملين
ما طبيعه الرد الروسي بالتالي
موجه نظرك
روسيا
اثناء العمليه العسكريه الخاصه لا
تعتمد على مبدا العين بالعين نحن نقوم
بتحقيق الاهداف التي وضعها السيد الرئيس
وهو ندع سلاح النظام الاوكراني وسوف نستمر
باعمالنا العسكريه وسفننا وغواصاتنا سوف
تخرج لمياه البحر الاسود وسوف توجه ضربات
صاروخيه ضد المنشات والاهداف العسكريه على
الاراضي الاوكرانيه وهذا سوف يستمر حتى
النصر الروسي واليوم دمرنا كل البنيه
التحتيه العسكريه في شواطئ البحر الاسود
في اسماعيل
واديسايف ومختلف الموانئ اليوم يجري
الحديث بان بايدن عن نقلا عن مسؤولين بان
رئيس بايدن وعد الرئيسكي بانه
سيقوم بتزويد اوكرانيا بعدد محدود من
صواريخ اتاكانس بعيده المدى صواريخ ارض
ارض حتى وان لم يؤكد البيت الابيض هذه
المعلومه لكنه لم ينفها ايضا
ما الذي ستغيره مثل هذه النوعيه من
الاسلحه مع وصول ايضا توقع وصول قريب
لدبابات ابرامز الامريكيه
سيدتي المقدمه المحترمه هذا لن يغير اي
شيء
ان قائد النظام في كيف نحن لا ننظر للمد
بالاسلحه نحن من ننتج الاسلحه
ولقد استطعنا ان نصل لقوات كبيره
وضاعفنا الانتاج العسكري الى اضعاف عديده
وكل الاسلحه المتواجده لدينا الان هي
اسلحه جديده الانتاج ونقوم بتعزيز قدراتنا
في الانتاج العسكري لذلك سوف نرد على هذا
التصعيد ولا نستطيع ان نقوم باي شيء اخر
الغرب سوف يقدم هذه الطواريخ وكل ما هو
ممكن لاوكرانيا وهذا ما تقوم به الغرب
وامريكا المهتمين بضعف باضعاف روسيا
وتزميرها ولا نستطيع ان نسمح لهذا ان يحدث
واؤكد انهم يلعبون بالنار ولا يواجه ويجب
ان لا ينسوا اننا دوله نوويه وفي
وفي حاله نقض العقيده العسكريه الروسيه
سوف نرد بكل القدرات شكرا لك من موسكو
العقيد باسيلي فاتيكا روز الضابط الاحتياط
في البحريه الروسيه شكرا على المشاركه
معنا